في الساعة الواحدة وخمسين دقيقة
بتوقيت فلسطين آآ اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه بدأ آآ تنفيذ آآ
غارات واهداف ضد قطاع غزة. بوتين
يشمر عن ساعديه ويشن هجوما مرعبا
على كيه. والثعلب الامريكي يعلن
موعد انتهاء الحرب وطباخ بوتين
يعود من جديد. فهل انتهت الخدعة?
واشنطن تبحث عن وسيط للحرب
الاوكرانية ومواجهة جوية بين
روسيا وبولندا والدفاع البولندية
ترد بتسليم كييف سربا من
الطائرات فكيف سترد موسكو?
والصين للاتحاد الاوروبي ثقتنا
بكم تنهار وستتحملون العواقب?
واصحاب العيون الضيقة يعيدون
مركبتهم من الفضاء بعد اكثر من
مائتين وخمسين يوما فماذا كانت
المهمة? والسودانيون يضعون الحرب
في كفة والحوار في كفة. فاي
الكفتين ستغلب والولايات المتحدة
تدخل ازمة غير مسبوقة وسوريا
تعود للاحضان العربية وحمى
الانتخابات تشتعل في تركيا. هجوم
روسي عنيف. بوتين يعلن نفادى
صبره ويوجه قواته لتصب جام غضبها
على القوات الاوكرانية. والحرب
تشتعل يا سادة. لتشن قوات موسكو
هجوما واسعا ومكثفا هو الاول من
منذ مدة طويلة بالطائرات المسيرة
والصواريخ مستهدفة العاصمة كييف
ومقاطعة جنوبية. وبعد هذا الهجوم
الكثيف اعلن الجيش الاوكراني
حالة التأهب الجوي في عموم
البلاد. وقال الجانب الاوكراني
ان دفاعاته اسقطت خلال هذا
الهجوم خمسا وثلاثين طائرة
مسيرة. بينما اكدت هيئة الاركان
الاوكرانية تنفيذ القوات الروسية
ستة عشر هجوما صاروخيا واحدى
وستين غارة اضافة الى خمسين
هجوما بمنظومات صاروخية اخرى.
فما كل هذه الهجمات ايها الدب
الروسي حان وقت الحسم هنا تظهر
نتيجة تلك الهجمات باعلان الدفاع
الروسية ان قواتها قضت على نحو
ستمائة وخمسة وعشرين جنديا
اوكرانيا على خمسة محاور قتال
اساسية خلال يوم واحد. ليضيف
الروس ان دفاعاتهم الجوية اسقطت
خمس مسيرة اوكرانية في مناطق
متفرقة. فعن اي خسائر نتحدث وها
هو طباخ بوتين قائد مجموعة فاغمر
يزيد الطين بلة على الاوكران.
ويؤكد ان قواته باقية في باخموت
بعد ان تلقى وعدا من الجيش
الروسي بتزويد تلك القوات
بالاسلحة والذخائر اللازمة
ومنحها صلاحية التصرف والتحرك في
باخموت بناء على ظروف المعركة.
هناك روسيا الستار عن مسرحية
انسحاب قوات فاغنر من باخموت.
فهل كان قرار الانسحاب من باخموت
خدعة روسية لاخفاء الهدف
الحقيقي؟ ما الذي تطبخه ايها
الطباخ؟ هنا اشتعلت اوكرانيا
غضبا لتطلق مسيراتها نحو العمق
الروسي مجددا. لكن جهاز امن
الدولة الروسي احبط هجوم المسيرة
الاوكرانية على مطار سيفيرني
العسكري في مقاطعة ايفانوفو لشرق
موسكو فهل نشهد ردا روسيا رادعا
هذه المرة? ومن بعيد يراقب
الغربيون كثافة الهجوم الروسي في
اوكرانيا واضعين ايديهم على
قلوبهم حابسين انفاسهم مترقبين
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد.
لتعلنها صحيفة واشنطن بوست
الامريكية صراحة. اوكرانيا قد
تلجأ للمفاوضات في حال ما فشلت
في تحقيق النجاح في المعركة
المحتملة. لنأتي لكم بما هو اكبر
من ذلك حيث تبحث الولايات
المتحدة وحلفاؤها الغربيون
امكانية لعب الصين دورا في
الوساطة لانهاء ازمة اوكرانيا
ويعد قبول واشنطن وساطة بكين
تحولا جذريا في الموقف الامريكي
الذي ينظر الى الصين على انها
داعمة للموقف الروسي حسب صحيفة
بول ستريت جورنال. فما هذا
التحول الفجائي للمواقف? يبدو ان
واشنطن عادت لرشدها وادركت ان
نهاية كل حرب هي المفاوضات
والحوار. لقد قلناها لكم سابقا
كل حرب مصيرها ان تنتهي
بالتفاوض. وها هو ثعلب السياسة
الامريكية وزير الخارجية
الامريكي السابق ومستشار الامن
القومي هنري كاسنجر يقول ان
الحرب الروسية الاوكرانية تقترب
من نقطة تحول. متوقعا اجراء
مفاوضات بحلول نهاية العام بفضل
الجهود الاخيرة التي تبذلها
الصين. لكن الغرب يعارض انهاء
النزاع الاوكراني. كما قال
الناطق باسم الرئاسة التركية
ابراهيم جلن نعم هكذا ترى تركيا
الصراع الاوكراني الروسي ليضيف
وزير الخارجية التركي مولود
شاووشوغلو ان بلاده لن تنضم الى
العقوبات احادية الجانب التي
تفرضها الولايات المتحدة
والاتحاد الاوروبي على روسيا.
وليست تركيا فحسب بل الاوروبيون
انفسهم فشلهم في الحرب
الاوكرانية الروسية. حيث قال
رئيس دبلوماسية الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيه بوريل ان النزاع في
اوكرانيا كشف خلافات الغرب مع
الاجزاء الاخرى من العالم. مضيفا
ان هذا الانقسام سيتعمق ويهدد
بالتحول الى هاوية. ومن الاتحاد
الاوروبي الى الهجوم الجوي. وبعد
ان تواجهت مقاتلة بولندية مع
مقاتلة روسية قبل ايام فوق البحر
الاسود بوخارست الحادث دليلا اخر
على النهج الاستفزازي للاتحاد
الروسي. اليكم المصدر. قالت
وزارة الدفاع الرومانية ان طائرة
مقاتلة روسية اعترضت في المجال
الجوي الدولي فوق البحر الاسود
طائرة بولندية كانت تقوم بمهمة
مع الوكالة الاوروبية لحرس
الحدود والسواحل. فمن يستفز من?
خصوصا بعد ان اعلن وزير الامن
القومي البولندي ماريوس بلاش
تشاك ان بولندا سلمت اوكراني عشر
مقاتلات تسعة وعشرين. وبالعودة
الى اوكرانيا اعلنت وزارة
المالية استلامها ما يقرب من
مائة وتسعين مليون يورو من البنك
الدولي كقرض لتغطية رواتب
الموظفين الحكوميين والمعلمين.
بكين تهدد واوروبا تندد. مع تقدم
الوقت يزداد التناقض. اوروبا
تتقرب من الصين وتطلب وساطتها مع
الروس من جهة من جهة اخرى. وبعد
ان كان الاتحاد الاوروبي قد اقر
الحزمة الجديدة للعقوبات
الاوروبية لتشمل سبع شركات صينية
متهمة بتزويد روسيا بالمعدات وفق
فاينانشيال تايمز ردت بكين
بتهديد قوي اذا فرض الاتحاد
الاوروبي عقوبات عليها بسبب
مساعدة روسيا وقال وانج وان
المتحدث باسم الخارجية الصينية
ان الثقة بين الاتحاد الاوروبي
والصين تنهار اذا تم فرض عقوبات
على شركات صينية بزعم انها تساعد
روسيا عن اي ثقة يتحدثون. ومن
المعارك الباردة على الارض هيا
لنقلع الى الفضاء. حيث قالت
وسائل اعلام صينية رسمية ان
مركبة فضاء صينية تجريبية عادت
الى الارض. بعد بقائها في المدار
لمدة مائتين وستة وسبعين يوما.
لتكمل بذلك مهمة تاريخية لاختبار
تقنيات قابلة لاعادة الاستخدام
في الفضاء. فما الذي تخفونه عنا
يا هؤلاء? السودان يختنق. قر وفر
على الارض السودانية وشد وجذب في
الاراضي السعودية. السودانيون ما
بين استمرار الحرب ومواصلة
الحوار. هنا الخارجية السعودية
تقول ان ممثلين عن القوات
المسلحة السودانية وقوات الدعم
السريع بدأوا محادثات تمهيدية في
مدينة جدة لوقف اطلاق النار
وتسهيل وصول مساعدات انسانية
طارئة الى السودان. وبينما تدور
لقاءات الحوار. يشهد السودان
اشتباكات في العاصمة الخرطوم بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع خاصة حول النقاط الحيوية
الاستراتيجية مع تحليق للطائرات
الحربية بمحيط القصر الرئاسي
ومركز الخرطوم لتسارع مضادات
الطيران التابعة للدعم الى الرد
معلنة ان مائة وثلاثين فردا من
الجيش السوداني بقيادة لواء
سلموا انفسهم بسبب حصار القيادة
العامة للجيش. الاحداث
والتطورات. في خطوة مثيرة للجدل.
اصدرت المحكمة العليا في
بريطانيا قرارا يسمح للشركات
المصنعة لمستحضرات التجميل
باستخدام الحيوانات في التجارب
العلمية لضمان جودة منتجاتها هذا
القرار بعد حظر قضائي دام خمسة
وعشرين عاما. الرئيس التركي
والمرشح الرئاسي عن تحالف
الجمهور رجب طيب اردوغان يقول لن
نسمح لكلشدار اوغلو الذي يعمل مع
المنظمات الارهابية بتقسيم
بلدنا. بينما يرد زعيم حزب الشعب
الجمهوري المعارض كمال كلجدار
اوغلو ستتوجهون الى صناديق
الاقتراع وستصوتون لصالح الحق.
ستصوت لصالح العدالة ولصالح
المواطن. وستقفون في وجه من
يتحدث معكم باستعلاء ومن يهددكم
لمدة اثنين وعشرين عاما. تجد
الولايات المتحدة نفسها على شفا
ازمة مالية غير مسبوقة بعد تأكيد
وزيرة خزانتها كل التدابير
الاستثنائية لتلافي تبعات وصول
البلاد الى حد الدين القانوني
البالغ واحدا وثلاثين واربعمائة
مليار دولار. وقد يتسبب الامر في
ضرر لا يمكن اصلاحه للاقتصاد
الامريكي وسبل عيش مواطنيه
والاستقرار المالي العالمي. قرر
مجلس الجامعة العربية على مستوى
وزراء الخارجية عودة سوريا لشغل
مقعدها بالجامعة بعد نحو اثني
عشر عاما على قرار تجميد عضويتها
بالجامعة. بوتين يكثف هجومه
والغرب يطلب الوساطة ماذا بعد
هذا كله برأيكم?